[Music]
and welcome back to careful boys and
today we've got ryan hasagawa in the
city
how's it going how's it going
is that how people are supposed to say
your name i guess
never had anyone say it like no actually
i take that back
so when i was in japan like i went to a
sushi restaurant like like a fan sushi
fancy sushi restaurant and then they saw
like my because then they're obviously
like serving like a bunch like tourists
and stuff like that as it's like because
it's fancy and people want to go when
they're in japan so then they're like
looking down the list and stuff and then
they see my name and i'm like like i'm
here for hacienda she's like oh i see
like her face like brightens up
then she starts like bouncing like oh no
how do i break it down i don't know what
japanese because she starts like
rattling off like you should have been
like
yeah
just a good old noise how did your
grandpa say your last name um
he said it kind of white to be honest
because i explained how
he's kind of like a like an asian giant
john wayne
your grandpa's a like an asian john
wayne yeah why are you dressed the way
you do yeah pretty much it's because i'm
like i want to be a cowboy no
because like he really liked america so
he just like watched a bunch of like
john wayne movies and [ __ ] like that so
he kind of talked like you know he kind
of had like a little bit of a draw like
sometimes and it was it was funny
because i was like i
ladies and gentlemen and he could speak
japanese too was he born here yeah
he was born in japan no he was born here
but he spent most of like a good chunk
of his childhood in japan kind of like
back and forth yeah so he was like i'm
like me and vegas yeah
no except not
where was he during the war during the
war he was actually close enough to when
to free up his hiroshima and nagasaki he
was in japan during world war ii whoa
when the bomb went off i was on the
wrong side no he was like i think he was
a kid so he was like close enough to
where the bomb went off that he got like
free medical service like free health
care did he get [ __ ] radiating no he
was like lucky that he was far enough
away but then they just like kind of
drew a line of like everybody in this
general area that could have gotten
[ __ ] up by the bomb like you get you
know free medical like you know health
care that's like the hurricane katrina
people whose houses didn't crumble but
they did some hookups yeah yeah that's
exactly like that except like replace
hurricane with nuclear bombs yeah yeah
yeah man-made yeah i forgot the part of
hurricane katrina people melted it
why did your grandpa go back and forth
from the u.s there's a lot of family
stuff there's just a lot of families
like your grandpa's so your
great-grandparents came here first yeah
yeah for work or whatever yeah i don't
know exactly what the story was i think
he was born in like oklahoma or nebraska
or something like that it was kind of
weird yes it was yeah so he was like
born in a very weird spot but then he
was like back and forth and eventually
he settled in california
um just because his or his his wife my
grandmother was like nah we gotta pick a
place we gotta [ __ ] stop moving
around and he's like john wayne
california
your grandma's born here too uh i don't
know about her actually i gotta double
check on that um i think she was though
yeah but um yeah they've we've my
family's been in the in the country for
a long last time so what are your fourth
generation it depends on what side of
the family but yeah third or fourth
generation depending on who you are you
always choose the men oh okay yeah i
think
if that's the case i think it's like
yeah i think i'm like third generation
or something they came here to teach
judo
to make sushi they came all the way over
here to make sushi and tell my
grandfather flip anything other than
like the finger
does your grandpa get offended like if
he was a stand-up comedian thing in
japan and someone made a bomb joke about
the i don't know i never i never pushed
that i
never shut up i never pushed that i
wonder like how soon after did japanese
stand-up comedians start making jokes
about them when it's accepted i don't
know anything about like japanese
stand-up is there a japanese phrase for
too soon probably
just let's go what is the phrase
i'll just like shake their head and like
oh my god no
is there a big stand-up comedy scene in
japan yeah that's the first question
of comics in japan for sure but like
traditional like one mic stool type of
[ __ ] i don't think it's i feel like it's
a lot on tv though right because i feel
like a lot of the comedians that i see
at least are like get on tv shows like
variety shows and stuff like that that's
true it's like like tara's house
castle dude there's an old art form
there's an old art form called
that i mean it just translates to like
like laughing but then it's it's it's
like a it's a comedy show it's a legit
comedy show they do sketches they do
commentary they do
uh like it's i don't know if it's improv
but that's the best way i can explain it
like they do games and stuff
um but i've like silent library yeah
yeah yeah that's that's hella japanese
but like
i've never seen a stand-up comedian but
also i wouldn't go because i can't
understand the complex adult [ __ ] oh
yeah
but i've been to uh shows and
performances where they do uh comedy
shows like that like it'll be like a um
a variety show that's what it is yeah
that's kind of like what they televised
though i was gonna say like i feel like
that's what they put on that's kind of
like who he is like a variety guy like
look at this whoa that explains the
traditional one is more like um
there's a format to it and it's like
life and then the the the one that we
see on tv is like a modern
variety show that probably took a lot of
influence from like the 60s in america
like that kind of prank shows that the
japanese do are so oh those are [ __ ]
great david was showing us one on his
podcast where
they they kept pranking the same guy
over and over again and he'd just be
walking and he walks onto like one
specific tile and he just drops into hot
water and they do that to him like seven
different times he was walking onto a
stage like in front of a performance
right when he walks in right
bro some [ __ ] joke reward he falls
right into the hot water and then
immediately right after he falls in the
hot water there's two guys in the back
pushing out a bucket of ice and he knows
the protocol as soon as he falls in the
ice the hot water he jumps into the ice
and he's just like cool himself off but
the best one is
they think they're done with the show he
gets into the tour bus he sits in the
back seat and as soon as he sits he
flips backwards
into a [ __ ] like a bowl of hot water
bro and he just once again the guys with
the bucket ice come out and they kept
doing it with this poor guy
i wish i wish we weren't so [ __ ] that
we couldn't enjoy it
you know what i mean it's so funny like
if we as a nation we call that bullying
in the u.s yeah if you try to shoot that
here be bullying there'll be a [ __ ]
activist saying you know cancer
someone's going to say is that guy like
a volunteer or is he part of the show
respect to the als [ __ ] patience yeah
yeah
like the ice bucket challenge people
yeah yeah i feel like everyone else has
better comedy shows than the us like the
[ __ ] that has better comedy the uk
whatever because they don't yeah i think
cause we have like a puritan like
so cause everybody thinks twice before
they really we are yeah we're a puritan
society
we're very anti-sex nobody shoots from
the hip with like comedy out here
they're just like they do and then
someone shoots back
yeah people are scared
yeah people are scared snipers people
are scared to push the boundaries versus
like stuff like that's [ __ ] tight man
i just think it's con convoluted though
sometimes like i feel like it's so
complex that someone doesn't want to
spend the time to like develop like a
false wall in all the tour buses to like
you know trick someone into getting it
on i feel like it takes a very specific
dedicated group of people to be like
that's what we're gonna get that's also
very japanese we're gonna dump the
entire [ __ ] budget under this trap
door mechanism and that's gonna be
[ __ ] sick yeah yeah we do have
jackass here yeah we have jackass yeah
but instead of regular comedy it's just
those are jackasses it's like not
but they only do that once a year and
[ __ ] you know now they do they used to
do it they used to do it seasonally yeah
yeah they used to do it seasonally now
they're just old
can you believe they're still [ __ ]
each other up at 50. this is the last
one like they're legit like they keep
saying that they keep saying that no but
this one i think that uh giant knoxville
got a concussion on this one that his
doctor's like you cannot do or you're
gonna die he gets a concussion every
move yeah well this is what he got
enough of a concussion that they're
gonna make him stop or something like
that like it's crazy that dude those
dudes are old but i'm gonna go watch
that movie though i'm gonna watch seen
that japanese prank show one where they
have to get an mri scan and then when
they get in the stretcher they go inside
and at the other side there's a grandma
and she's like [ __ ] one inch away
from your face and you're just eskimo
kissing her that's pretty funny okay
i want to know who that ground was and
you can't laugh you got to just stay
still yeah
there was one silent library i saw where
it was like
it was it like when they picked a card
and it said gums or something like that
oh yeah an old man and ernesto hoost
yeah he's like one of the he's like the
one of the goat kickboxers of all time
of all time big
black dutch i think he's dutch yeah
dutch dude and he just yeah he's with a
bunch of these tiny little japanese
dudes in the library and there's this
old man that comes out he puts out his
teeth and he starts sucking in this
dude's ear
and the whole time
and he's just trying to hold it together
but it's like one of the best things
ever they bring all these fighters on
like the most hardcore bob sapp like
these type of dudes and they'll bring
them into the silliest environments
that's great they love that [ __ ] have
you seen the one where they had to go
around this this tube and someone farted
in it you know they had to put gossip
like the oxygen masks on
yeah
i've seen that one on jackass yeah oh
yeah i think stevo like yaks
so it's like he's like
in the thing so it's adding to the to
the experience dude remember that
jackass where one of their buddies had a
[ __ ] run on the treadmill and they
had the sweat bag and nephew had a drink
to that
[ __ ]
bro dude that one that one's the one
that got me the closest to you yeah that
was true i was like
what about when that guy ate a piece of
[ __ ] do you guys remember that one it
was three six mafia have you seen that
that was in the movie
which one it was like a piece of like
cow [ __ ] or something oh
three six mafia's there the [ __ ] chip
thing yeah and he eats it and i was like
i can't do this anymore i can't watch it
i can't do it i'm glad this conversation
came from talking about your
grandparents he would he would approve
nagasaki
it's like can you believe all the people
who fought for our freedoms during world
war ii if they saw what humans are doing
today
dude i know man they'd probably be like
this is sick
you guys got something called jackass
that's great this is cool yeah let me
see that this is this is the
civilization that we saved
dudes drinking each other's sweat
today's video is brought to you by
babble babble
you know um i always had the hardest
time learning a new language
teachers always say you're stupid but
you know i always mean school
you stupid you're stupid but i always
thought like
learning language through a textbook
through lecture all that stuff it just
made it so much more difficult than
trying to do it in an interactive way
yeah that's why babel is pretty awesome
because it's a really quick method
that's proven to work because they have
a ton of language experts that help
develop this learning program yeah
there's over a hundred
and they also have quick uh 15-minute
sessions so you can learn really fast
with digestible so it's not like class
where you're sitting there for like a
whole hour trying to absorb everything
you could just do it on the go 15
minutes four times a day is still an
hour and you can learn it much faster
that way and what's cool is they have 14
different languages that you can choose
from like
spanish italian german
and one of the dopest things it has
speech recognition technology so instead
of just like a one-way language app you
actually get to talk back and then you
can get your enunciation corrected
so if you're tired of your language
teacher talking [ __ ] to you calling you
stupid else stupid though maybe you
could do a little extra studying on the
side if you know what i'm talking about
because right now they got a sick deal
if you go to babble.com off the record
for three months you get another three
months free so that's six months for the
price of three go to babel b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com slash off the record to get six
months for the price of three months
ryan i have a question for you sure
who's your favorite japanese person my
favorite japanese male and female go i
don't know a whole lot japanese american
or japanese japanese you heard what i
said dude japanese japanese
i give it both i gotta say japanese
twice like they're not japanese japanese
yeah people emphasize
you're next joe i should be called twice
removed and he should be called three
times removed japanese yeah i mean the
more generations you get in america just
the more the more white you get the
banana strengthens with like they have
to be real people are counting people
like ryu
fictional japanese counselors do you
consider pikachu japanese that's what
i'm saying
yeah but he's not a person pikapi but
he's
japanese is
ash is a person like a shiba inu is a
japanese yeah
he said person i think are you are you
okay with either japanese things yes
japanese entities
japanese i like matcha a lot japanese
characters what's your favorite japanese
phrase
it's kind of like the most american
japanese guy here yeah no that's funny
everyone always brings it up they're
just like oh we got a japanese guy i'm
like don't that's not that's a question
then that pertains to only you would you
rather have the best gun on in the
planet or the best camera in the world
oh that's a good question probably the
best camera in the world because like
because you're still shooting someone's
going to jack you for it though because
you ain't got no gun
yeah i guess but if i got a gun then
i can't take a picture of it right after
the guy gives him the camera he goes now
give me the camera
those are the biggest passions guns and
cameras so cameras over guns for you
well yeah because i can make mo i can
make a lot more money with that you
could you could make a lot of money now
but then i have to be on the run all the
time like i don't want to be like
stressing out about a life of crime all
the time if you get a sick ass gun you
also get a sick ass road car
and a holster
so but i just have to constantly be
driving it okay fine you also get a
driver oh you're the driver no stop
questioning the logistics i don't want
to run for the rest of my life like i'm
not running and driving
but what if you're running for the law
not from or the law
what am i because you're you're because
you're a cop or something you know
you're running for the law you know this
is for the law it's like a jog-a-thon it
sounds like a police charity
it's a police jock-a-thon it's for a
west coast
like he wants you to donate
he's just stopping at your house running
in place
you're running uh to catch a bad guy
because you're a cop okay i'll i'll uh
i'll meet you in the middle
again i'll give you a sniper
that the scope is the best camera in the
world
stupid what your car is hella wack but
every time every time you shoot
every time you shoot you take a picture
yeah but you'll pull a shirt so i have
evidence yeah every time you shoot you
take a gorgeous photo of the victim yeah
and before they died
to classical music
that's a black mirror episode before
they die
that's the trade-off yeah is that okay
that would actually be so helpful in
shooting because when you're shooting
long distance right the reason why you
have a spotter is after you you pull the
trigger the things shake so much you're
off site so you don't know where you're
looking at but if you could actually
take a picture at the moment you pulled
the trigger what the sight picture looks
like dude i think you just invented
something you're welcome
because then you you gotta be like this
if you're spotter hit
yeah hit two degrees to the right
spend enough time with each other you
guys start making out i know and they're
not even spotting it is there does that
happen do they get romantically marines
marines is something else man
[Laughter]
just [ __ ] it a bunch of times they
finish each other's sentences it's not
really i think they're finishing is that
syndrome instead of them being like this
side to side
[Applause]
literally on top of me because the
recoil broke so when i shoot to
stabilize oh [ __ ] oh yeah oh i just
busted oh [ __ ] dude that's [ __ ] crazy
right dude
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
so then recoil
machine gun
baby you're really gonna have a hard
time exactly for stability you have to
like go inside oh yeah you gotta link up
you gotta be one you gotta be one
shooter that's right plugging in it's
like kayaks right when you get in the
kayak the bigger guy has to be in the
back the smaller person has to be in the
front so as a smaller person i'll be in
the front the bigger guy gives me
stability on top of me and you have to
leak but then why does the middle guy
have to take it from both sides
it's just it's just protocol bro how
many people
does everybody
ride kayaks that way well he's a
connecting course
he's the connecting audience
he's the conductor so are we gonna get a
girl on the show or not
[Laughter]
what's the deal bro
i heard there's a girl coming soon
yeah to a theater near you
she's just gonna enable all of them how
come girls will do jokes like that
really oh yeah there's this there's a
sniper
do military girls make jokes like that i
don't think so not really yeah they
don't
guys in the room are like yeah and yeah
then what happens next man i love this
joke
that's so funny [ __ ] yeah can you
say it a little bit slower next time
yes
i gotta put on my army hat for that one
dude looks like you're fishing here
talking about military we talked about
japanese prank shows and we talked about
your japanese heritage so i think we're
covering all your don't forget
photography yeah my two my only two
passions is guns and guns and cameras
but none of you guys have like a like a
iconic japanese person who is your
favorite japanese kid
i like him
mikey
dude that guy's insane i will say no
yeah that's cool as [ __ ] he's a japanese
director and his filmography is [ __ ]
insane he's done [ __ ] like [ __ ] um
like uh uh audition with it's like this
horror movie where this it's it's known
for this like super brutal torture scene
where like this chick like basically
like tortures this guy to death and like
cuts like things off of his feet and
stuff like that so insane [ __ ] like that
and then he also directs family movies
like what kind of family movies like
there's shrek three
[Laughter]
ryan have you seen this movie called
happiness of the korres kurotakis or
kurosawas it's this like family that
inherits this like uh motel and then
they're gonna start running this motel
but people keep dying inside their motel
so they have to keep hiding the bodies
and then it's but it's done as like a
family comedy off that sounds hilarious
that sounds pretty funny so it's like a
little bit of horror when people die and
the ghost come back to haunt them but
they're also like like like slapstick
kind of like trying to like hide the
feet underneath the japanese we can have
bernie's yeah it's funny though like so
that's that's his filmography so that's
that's a good choice what was his name
again uh takeshi
yeah mikey got two eyes m-i-i-k-e yeah
so that dudes that dude's got like if i
if i work on that many kinds of films by
the end of my career i'll be a very
happy man what if he go what if he goes
is he alive i think so yeah dude he's
old though i want to hire you but you
have to give up guns for the rest of
your life oh no i probably wrong
he's american dude he's like don't take
my [ __ ] guns from me you wouldn't you
would say no i make my own movement try
to give him guns the rest of my life
what a weird uh like a request for
someone who gains nothing but it's your
dream career though yeah but i'll shoot
another film that's cool yeah what a
class this guy's demanding
i don't like guns but i like you yeah
but
like i wouldn't even be guns would be
nowhere near him he just wants me as a
person to give up
he just wants to hurt me you don't keep
a gun on set if dave chappelle said like
i could live with him and then he'll
like take me under his wing uh-huh and i
have to give up guns i'll say [ __ ] you
let's do it oh you don't think about the
you know you live with him and you give
up your family part
you'll never see your family again
what if he asks you to be vegan for the
rest of your life that'd be tough rest
of my life you have to give up red meat
you have to go vegan
or you're not allowed to get like a fade
anymore
[Laughter]
you gotta feed opposite you gotta go you
have to drive a smart car for the rest
of your life
never would have been hair salon
yeah but vegan though
vegan's tough i'll tell you i think i'll
do it yeah yeah interesting wow
just not the family part but like
everything else is
everything else is like professional
right it's like it's not like a uh deal
breaker it's like i could do anything
change i can't believe you like comedy
more than guns what's wrong with you
he's the goat though get to learn from
him
what if he's like a really bad teacher
yeah what if he's like a great athlete
but a horrible coach what if he's like
what if he's like you got to put this
bumper sticker on your truck for 30
years and it says marines are gay
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
think most of those jokes i've heard
from marie
[Music]
you